so I'd like to talk a little bit more
about this technique
Coda guys
so now we've got uh
inwards and outwards
in woods and outwards
we've got this coat of guys
where we we break the thumb Gap here all
right so this one I attack
the thumb and Breakout and my hand blade
is flat flat
but that can be sticky
right but the more you yeah do that the
more it will come out
well I showed you just for the tea break
was
the inward one
but it mustn't come in as in
but the circle is in where the other one
is out
okay so I want you to do them both out
in
out
downgrades
give you a little bit more but take it
cue Grace take it if you get it
there this thumbnail those who throw a
rim and Aggie we add this little
this piece this thumbs goes down we add
that
in a romanagi
I'm now going to go
a little press it is that's got a little
press
so I've got to again be a magician quick
with my hands
if you want to do the whole car guys do
the whole coat of gosh
mustn't come into you
always away always away
I've told you so many different things
over the years about all these points
okay
guys
okay so when you've got so you've got a
sodium
all right so you've got an in and out
okay double